When I realized that losing your
temper was a sign of weakness.
As soon as I read, as soon
as I made that connection,
I said to myself this week I'm
gonna try not to do it anymore.
And what's weird is when you're a kid,
I don't know if you remember this,
but when I was a kid and you'd see
someone get angry and it made you afraid.
And so for a while I saw it
as like a power, you know,
it's kind of a way to achieve power that
you can lose your temper and then all
of a sudden you have this extra strength.
And so when you're a little kid,
and when I say a little kid, I mean when
I was 1314 years old, I thought, hey,
if I go, if I could get that rage
going, and people are scared,
like I used to feel. That's a
positive thing. And then like I said,
as I got older, now you, you know,
now you're talking 1615
1617 I realized, hey,
this isn't,
yeah,
this isn't cool. This isn't
strength, it's actually weakness.
And when I realized it was weakness,
and I didn't realize that overnight,
but I started getting the
idea that that was weakness.
And now
when you see someone that is in control
and even when bad things are happening
there, you know, there's, there's
standing stoically saying, okay,
let me take another look at that and
I'll get it done. You know what I mean?
When they're just okay, then you realize,
okay, this guy's really unflappable,
which is a lot more impressive. So again,
you, you gotta be able to
detach from this. And you know,
I like to take pride in the fact that
I'm gonna keep my cool no matter what
happens. And definitely once I was in
that, once you're in the seal teams,
you definitely want to be
that guy that's keeping your,
keeping your cool no
matter what's happening,
whether it's people are doing the wrong
thing or you just want to be the guy
that's, hey, okay, come back
over here. We need to Redo this.
You just want to be that guy that's way
more impressive than the guy that does
not get bullied. Don't be that person.
So, and I've talked about this before,
what are the pre event indicators that
show you or reveal to you that your
temper is about to be lost? What are
they? Is it you clench your fist,
right? Is it you raise your voice and
you start doing it, doing that stuff?
Do you start to heavy breathing? Do
you flow, flair your nostrils, right.
Cause that's an animal thing where
you're going to take in more oxygen.
So you open up the nostrils cause
you're about to get after it. Do you,
you know, use your, does your, your
head, you know, shaking or whatever.
You can just like these
things. What is it,
what indicators do you have when you know
that you're starting to feel that and
as soon as you feel that you're detach,
you go, oh, that's what that is.
That's an indicator and it's a
weakness and I don't like weakness,
so I'm not going to allow it. And then,
yeah, take a breath.
Okay.
I like to say, know what?
Here's a good one. You want to,
you want to get through that, that moment.
Nod your head slowly in the affirmative,
right? So, so when someone's telling
me something that's making me mad,
I'll just slowly nod my head. Like,
I understand this is the way things are.
I accept this and this is
calculating what my next move is
gonna be. Uh, and then, you know,
you're seeing whatever, you know,
guys will count to 10. You know,
you tell you a little kids that tell
you a little kids when they start losing
their temper, you know what?
You need to count to 10 count
to 10 count to a hundred,
counter thousand or whatever did
you gotta do and get control.
Because like I said, if you're losing
control, it's not strike it's weakness.